ministre mes chers collègues la séance
est ouverte le compte rendu analytique
de la précédente saison 7 distribuée il
n'y a pas d'observation le procès-verbal
est adopté sous les réserves d'usage
j'informe le Sénat que deux candidatures
pour siéger au sein de la CMP chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant discussions du projet de loi
portant en mesure d'urgence relative au
fonctionnement du marché du travail en
vue du plein emploi ont été publiés ces
candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement
du jour rappelle la discussion du projet
de loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable la
procédure accélérée a été engagée sur ce
texte dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame agnèse de la
transition énergétique vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
Monsieur les présidents de commission
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
2/3 c'est aujourd'hui la part d'énergie
fossile dans notre consommation
d'énergie du pétrole du gaz pour
l'essentiel importer du reste du monde
le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables ne représentent donc qu'un
tiers de la totalité de notre
consommation d'énergie
ce qui signifie qu'à consommation égale
il faudrait multiplier par 3 notre
production d'énergie bas carbone pour
compenser la sortie des énergies
fossiles
c'est la date à laquelle 26 de nos 56
réacteurs nucléaires arriveront au terme
de 50 années d'exploitation
tous devront alors passer le cap d'une
visite de sécurité exigeante pour être
prolongée 10 années de plus en matière
énergétique 2035 c'est demain
plus 60%
. c'est selon RTE la proportion
d'électricité que nous devrons produire
en plus à l'horizon 2050 si nous voulons
enfin sortir des énergies fossiles
atteindre la neutralité carbone et
répondre à nos besoins croissants
d'électrification pour l'industrie les
transports et les bâtiments
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ces
trois éléments montrent bien que nous
sommes à un tournant historique si nous
voulons atteindre la neutralité carbone
si nous voulons enfin devenir maître de
notre destin énergétique nous ne
pourrons nous passer d'aucune énergie
des carbonée nucléaires comme
renouvelables tant la marche à franchir
est élevée et lorsque je dis
renouvelable je veux être clair je parle
bien de toutes les énergies
renouvelables je sais que vous y êtes
sensible celle qui produisent de
l'électricité mais aussi de la chaleur
géothermie biomasse biométhane éolienne
terrestre et marine hydraulique etc ce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui
nous donne un avant-goût de ce qui nous
attend demain si nous n'agissons pas
d'abord la crise climatique qui provoque
les dérèglements que nous constatons
tous sécheresse canicule feu nous vivons
nous venons de vivre en France le mois
d'octobre le plus chaud qu'on est connu
l'urgence est là devant nous
ensuite la crise énergétique la plus
grave depuis les années 70 de voir
importer des énergies sans en maîtriser
le coup nous le voyons c'est affaiblir
le pouvoir d'achat des Français c'est
peser sur la compétitivité de nos
entreprises c'est réduire les capacités
d'action des collectivités locales
face à ces enjeux nous ne sommes pas
sans solution nous connaissons les
leviers que nous devons activer pour
être à la hauteur du défi les économies
d'énergie tout d'abord grâce à la
sobriété l'efficacité énergétique je ne
reviendrai pas sur le plan sobriétique
nous avons annoncé avec la première
ministre ça s'ajoute aux actions menées
en matière d'efficacité énergétique ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que d'ici 2050
nous devons réduire de 40% notre
consommation d'énergie pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone la production massive
d'énergie renouvelable ensuite c'est
l'enjeu du plan énergie renouvelable que
j'ai lancé en juin dernier qui a permis
de débloquer 10 gigawatts de production
électrique un terrawatts de biométhane
il a aussi permis de mobiliser les
services de l'État de renforcer les
équipes d'instruction sur le terrain
d'accélérer les raccordements je sais
aussi que ce sont des enjeux auxquels
vous êtes sensibles ce texte qui vous
est présenté aujourd'hui et le volet
législatif de ce plan énergies
renouvelable que nous allons continuer à
déployer
quels sont les grands chapitres de notre
stratégie énergétique il nous appartient
maintenant de les décliner dans une
nouvelle programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie qui tiennent compte de la
nécessité de réhausser notre ambition
climatique et d'accélérer notre sortie
des énergies fossiles nous avons démarré
ce travail comme nous y invite la loi en
lançant en octobre une grande
consultation publique elle est inédite
par son ampleur car l'enjeu est de
taille ce travail il vous sera
intégralement restitué et nourrira vos
réflexions dans le cadre du projet de
loi qui vous sera soumis en 2023 pour
mettre à jour notre mix énergétique
alors pourquoi ce projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables pourquoi ne pas
attendre 2023
tout simplement parce qu'à l'heure où
nous voyons que nous allons devoir
mettre encore plus d'ambition dans la
production d'énergie nous ne pouvons que
constater que nous sommes déjà en retard
sur la production des énergies
renouvelables il nous faut donc
rattraper sur retard et c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce projet vous l'avez compris
le combat amener c'est celui des
énergies bac carbone contre les énergies
fossiles c'est je pense un choix qui
s'inscrit dans une position constante de
notre pays depuis le cri d'alarme
poussée à Johannesburg par le président
Jacques Chirac en passant par le
Grenelle de l'environnement conduit par
Nicolas Sarkozy et Jean-Louis Borloo où
les accords de Paris portés par François
Hollande et Laurent Fabius ce texte qui
vous est présenté le fruit des échanges
que j'ai eu depuis plusieurs mois avec
des acteurs associatifs économiques élus
locaux et leur association et très en
amont avec vous les parlementaires des
différents groupes du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée à cet égard je souhaite
souligner la qualité des échanges et du
travail conduit par les deux rapporteurs
did et Patrick Chauvet et par les
présidents des commissions du
Développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du territoire d'une part
et des affaires économiques d'autre part
jean-françois-longjo et Sophie prima je
tiens aussi à souligner la mobilisation
de la commission des affaires
culturelles et le travail qui a été mené
par la rapporteur pour avis Laurence
Garnier comme vous le savez je n'y
reviens pas ce projet de loi à quatre
objectifs accélérer et procédures
environnement administratives sans rien
enlever à nos exigences
environnementales libéré du foncier
dégradé permettre une planification par
grande façades maritime pour les
éoliennes marines améliorer enfin le
partage de la valeur de ces projets et
sécuriser le coût de l'énergie au profit
des habitants des collectivités locales
et des entreprises
le texte sorti de commission montre
qu'il existe en fait de fortes
convergences au sein des différents
groupes pour aboutir à une loi qui
facilite le déploiement des projets
d'énergie renouvelables en remettant les
collectivités au cœur de la
planification et énergétique et en
visant à haut niveau d'exigence en
termes de nombre de projets réalisés que
ce soit l'idée d'élargir certaines
mesures au biométhane ou d'intégrer un
article sur la gros voltaïsme reprenant
une proposition de loi largement votée
sur ses bancs des enrichissements ont
été apportés et nous les soutiendrons
bien volontiers la question la plus
difficile reste cependant à finaliser
celle de la manière dont l'état les élus
locaux et les porteurs de projets
travaillent ensemble pour permettre un
développement certes rapide mais
raisonner et équilibrer des énergies
renouvelables cela pose la question de
l'implantation des projets au cœur des
territoires comment répondre-t-il aux
besoins énergétiques de ces territoires
comment mobiliser et associer les
acteurs locaux comment minimiser autant
que possible leur impact sur la
biodiversité et leur nuisance sur les
communes voisines comment ces projets se
font-ils dans les paysages et
cohabitent-ils bien avec les habitants
au regard du retour d'expérience en la
matière certains projets sont
incontestablement des succès d'autres ne
le sont pas et nous devons le
reconnaître ces échecs expliquent les
réticences
manifestent à raison de territoires qui
ne souhaitent pas connaître les mêmes
difficultés cela doit nous faire
réfléchir à une nouvelle méthode de
conduite de ses projets et je crois
pouvoir dire au regard de mes nombreux
échanges avec vous ainsi qu'avec des
élus locaux et associations d'élus que
nous sommes
unanimement alignés sur ce diagnostic ce
constat d'une nécessité de changement de
méthode est à l'origine de nombreux
amendements que nous examinerons qui
encadrent plus fortement les projets
d'énergie renouvelables mais je le
crains au risque de les freiner dans ce
contexte notre responsabilité commune
est bien de prendre en compte ces
réticences tout en veillant à ne pas
céder à la tentation de l'immobilisme la
question est de savoir comment
notre vision de la planification
énergétique n'est pas une planification
descendante bien au contraire la
planification que nous appelons de nos
vœux est une planification qui remet les
collectivités locales et les territoires
au centre des décisions à cet égard je
vais être très clair le gouvernement ne
reviendra pas sur la suppression de la
mise en compatibilité des documents
d'urbanisme par le préfet je m'y étais
engagé auprès de vous monsieur le
rapporteur ainsi qu'auprès des
associations d'élus la planification que
j'appelle de mes vœux fait des élus des
partenaires et leur donne les leviers
pour agir et qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté je vous rejoins monsieur le
rapporteur sur le fait que les maires
doivent pouvoir avoir d'une certaine
manière le dernier mot sur des projets
structurants pour leur territoire mais
cela doit être précédé d'une volonté de
planifier le déploiement de ces projets
d'énergie renouvelables et cela peut se
faire en s'appuyant sur les documents
d'urbanisme
nos élus peuvent davantage pour nos
énergies et planifier c'est plus orienté
qu'interdire
accompagnez-nous dans le déploiement des
projets nous disent ces élus car nous
voulons le faire l'État doit donner le
cap pour l'ensemble du pays et être
ensuite facilitateur auprès de chaque
territoire c'est le sens de l'amendement
numéro 645 du gouvernement il propose
que les élus définissent des zones
prioritaires pour les énergies
renouvelables au niveau des scottes tout
en maintenant les dispositions de la loi
3DS sur lesquels les sénateurs d'Arnaud
et Gatel étaient rapporteurs en
permettant de prévoir des zones où le
développement des éoliennes terrestres
seraient encadrés afin d'inciter les
porteurs de projets à déposer des
projets dans ces zones l'état pourra
prévoir des bonifications dans ces
appels d'offres à organiser des appels
d'offres dédiées à ces zones
privilégiées aux prioritaires de plus
cet amendement donnera la possibilité
aux maires ou à l'EPCI de s'opposer une
zone d'implantation prioritaire sur son
territoire le maire aura ainsi le
dernier mot dans un processus de
planification réfléchi et volontaire au
regard de cette proposition complète et
équilibrée le gouvernement demandera la
suppression des articles premier a et
premier C par ailleurs s'agissant des
éoliennes en mer se pose la question des
zones d'implantation et leur distance de
la côte on retrouve au fond le même type
de débat en tant que ministre
responsable de notre transition
énergétique je ne dois vous dire qu'à ce
jour et au regard des avancées
technologiques une distance
d'implantation des éoliennes en mer de
plus de 40 km des côtes réduirait très
significativement notre potentiel de
développement elle nous prévoit d'un
levier majeur alors qu'un parquet éolien
en mer de 2 gigawatts c'est l'équivalent
de la production d'un réacteur nucléaire
avec cette disposition nous ne pourrons
plus lancer de projets même flottants et
c'est logique en mer du Nord et dans la
Manche comprend bien pourquoi et même en
Méditerranée compte tenu des canyones
qui existent en mer Méditerranée seul
l'océan atlantique pourrait accueillir
des projets notamment en large de la
Bretagne et des Pays de Loire c'est
également je crois
un très mauvais signal envoyé à des
filières industrielles qui sont
aujourd'hui et c'est une chance pour la
France les plus compétitives au plan
mondial largement exportatrice aux
États-Unis en Écosse elle représente
près de 6600 emplois directs notamment à
Cherbourg au Havre ou encore à
Saint-Nazaire on n'a pas beaucoup de
filières d'énergie renouvelable qui soit
aussi puissante prenons garde à les
ménager et à les développer c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
proposera de revenir à la rédaction
initiale du texte dans son amendement
numéro 584 à l'article 12
au-delà de ces deux éléments je tiens à
saluer le travail qui a été mené en
commission afin d'enrichir le texte les
nombreux apports qui ont été faits
concours pleinement à l'objectif
d'accélération des énergies du texte
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je suis confiante sur le fait que nous
trouvons le chemin du consensus avec
tous ceux et ils sont nombreux dans
cette émission et sur le terrain qui
défendent la souveraineté énergétique et
politique de notre pays
avec tous ceux qui veulent défendre le
pouvoir d'achat des Français et la
compétitivité des entreprises avec tous
ceux qui veulent lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
nous n'avons pas le luxe d'attendre pour
sortir des énergies fluophiles vous le
savez les Français nous regardent je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Didier
mandeli rapporteur de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable pour 10 minutes
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
sur le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues une semaine après
l'examen en commission les revenus
d'examiner dans cette hémicycle le
projet de loi relatif à l'accélération
de la production d'énergie renouvelable
je veux aussi saluer préambule le
travail des administrateurs de la
commission Vincent Carole et Victor sans
oublier Stéphanie remercier mes
collègues de la commission pour leur
participation aux auditions et au
travail de la commission et vous
remercie madame la ministre pour la
qualité de nos échanges depuis plusieurs
semaines comme la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et de
développement durable la noter c'est la
première fois qu'un projet de loi est
intégralement consacré à ces énergies
c'est un signal politique fort dont nous
nous réjouissons rappelons ici avec
fermeté sans ambiguïté
ces énergies sont nécessaires la
préservation de notre souveraineté à
l'atteinte de nos outils de nos
objectifs climatiques constatons
également avec lucidité que la France
est très en retard dans leur déploiement
c'est même le seul pays de l'Union
européenne n'est pas avoir atteint ses
objectifs en la matière en 2020 dans le
cadre de la PPE nous avons voté ici nous
pouvons évidemment nous satisfaire de ce
retard qui affaiblit notre pays notre
commission par partage donc pleinement
l'objectif de ce texte celui d'accélérer
le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables ce constat est en dressé
nous devons dans un second temps nous
poser la question de l'adéquation de ce
texte aux enjeux énergétiques et
climatiques le projet de loi qui nous a
été proposé est-il suffisant nous
pouvons en douter tout d'abord car ce
texte semble précipité on ne peut que
regretter la méthode consistant à
abordée par ce projet de loi l'exception
et particulier avant le cadre général il
était préférable bien sûr pour la clarté
du travail parlementaire de débattre
préalable des objectifs de développement
filière par filière dans le cadre de la
loi quinquennale que nous aurons examiné
en 2023
deuxième regret le projet de loi proposé
est décevant et abouti dans son ambition
simplificatrice peu de mesure du texte
initial sont nature accélérées
substantiellement les projets en
particulier sur le plan des procédures
administratives même en supposant que le
texte proposé et son volet réglementaire
dans ses parallèlement cet été
permettent de simplifier ponctuellement
les procédures et toutes majeures
existent quant à la capacité des
services déconcentrés de l'État à
répondre aux besoins et inscrire
l'ensemble des dossiers à effectifs
constants dernier grief formulé par
notre commission peut déplorer de
nombreux oublies et sujets non traités
dans le texte initial fort de ces
constats notre commission souhaitait
relever l'ambition du texte proposé elle
l'a indiscutablement fait en le
complétant et en l'améliorant
substantiellement le premier axe de
travail sur lequel nous avons avancé
porte sur la planification territoriale
et l'amélioration de la concertation
autour des projets d'implantation
d'énergie renouvelables il s'agissait
d'un véritable angle mort du texte
initial nous savons pourtant que le
manque d'acceptabilité ce qui empêche
véritablement un projet d'énergie
renouvelable de se dép
notre commission a donc proposé
l'instauration d'un dispositif global de
planification territoriale
du déploiement des énergies
renouvelables je dis bien globale car
l'enjeu est moins de déterminer quel
document identifierait les zones de
développement des énergies renouvelables
que d'instituées une méthode de
concertation permettant leur
identification en cohérence avec les
objectifs nationaux nous avons donc
composé que les maires puis les
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale en lien avec les
syndicats d'énergie département et enfin
les comités régionaux de l'énergie soit
à la manœuvre pour définir des oses
propices à l'implantation des
installations de production d'énergie
renouvelable pour ce faire ils pourront
s'appuyer sur une estimation du
potentiel de production de leur
territoire qui leur seraient transmise
par l'État une fois ces zones définies
il reviendra ensuite et seulement
ensuite à l'état des avalisés par décret
ces zones pourront alors bénéficier de
souplesse qui permettront d'accélérer
substantiellement le développement des
projets concernés à côté de cette
planification générale nous avons
souhaité instituer une planification
spatiale et temporelle spécifique au
développement des projets éoliens en mer
de nombreux acteurs critiquent la
méthode actuelle qui consiste à
développer des projets par aku sans
visibilité quand on nombre de projets
envisagés à moyen terme sur une même
façade ou aux zones précis dans
lesquelles ces projets pourront pourrait
s'implanter afin de favoriser
l'acceptabilité sociale des projets
éloignants nous avons souhaité que ce
soit prioritairement ciblés j'insiste
surpris au prioritairement ciblé pour
les futurs appels d'offres des zones
d'implantation situées dans la zone
économique exclusive afin d'orienter
l'État et les porteurs de projets vers
la technologie prometteuse de l'éolien
flottant qui devrait arriver à maturité
commerciale à l'horizon 2030 2035 j'ai
également proposé que soit privilégié
encore et j'insiste des implantations de
l'un d'une distance de 40 km du rivage
bien entendu il ne s'agit pas là d'une
obligation cette règle va être mise en
oeuvre en tenant compte des contraintes
existantes sur chaque façade l'idée
d'impulser une tendance à l'éloignement
des parcs vis-à-vis des côtes lorsque
cela est possible en laissant le
gouvernement toute la latitude
nécessaire
autre proposition forte nous avons
souhaité renforcer la voie des élus
locaux en leur permettant de s'exprimer
favorablement ou défavorablement sur
l'implantation d'une série de projets
d'énergie renouvelables les élus sont
les plus à même de savoir quels sont les
projets les plus pertinents pour leur
territoire il faut leur redonner un
pouvoir décisionnel je l'assume car je
sais que la grande majorité des élus est
en faveur du développement des énergies
renouvelables faisons leur confiance
nous avons également souhaité associer
plus étroitement les particuliers
entreprises associations et
collectivités territoriales à proximité
d'un site d'implantation en demandant au
porteur de projets de leur proposer une
participation à l'investissement au
capital comme cela existe au Danemark
par exemple nous avons également
largement avancé sur notre deuxième axe
de travail consacré à la simplification
sur ce volet nous allons proposer un
nouvel équilibre dans la législation
environnementale reposant sur trois
piliers
le premier plus de concertation avec le
public et les élus en amont du dépôt
formel des demandes d'autorisation des
projets en deux une instruction plus
rapide des projets avec des dossiers de
meilleure qualité de fait dès lors des
peaux et en trois une simplification en
aval pour la consultation du public avec
des ajustements pragmatiques dans ce
cadre nous avons notamment proposé de
supprimer certains dispositifs qui ne
sont plus pertinents à l'heure actuelle
et source de charges pour les services
d'administratifs à l'image du certificat
de projet dans le cadre de
l'autorisation environnementale nous
avons souhaité également créer un
référent unique au sein des préfectures
de chaque département pour faciliter
l'instruction de tous les projets visés
par le texte tous les projets énergies
renouvelables guichet unique référent
unique et encore bien d'autres mesures
dont la création d'un fonds de garantie
pour couvrir les risques contentieux la
création de nouvelles dérogations
procédurale temporaire
notre troisième axe de travail porte sur
la libération de surface de déploiement
un faible enjeu environnementaux foncier
car nous sommes convaincus que notre
politique de décarbonation ne nous
permettra pas de relever les défis de
demain si elle conduit dans le même
temps au dépassement d'autres limites
planétaires planétaire que sont
l'érosion de la biodiversité et le
changement d'utilisation des sols nous
avons donc proposé de renforcer les
obligations de couverture en énergie
solaire des bâtiments non résidentiels
existants et nouveaux afin d'anticiper
les orientations européennes
consécutives au déclenchement de la
guerre en Ukraine en contrepartie de ces
obligations nous avons souhaité
faciliter l'achat de procédés de
production d'énergie renouvelable afin
d'équiper ces bâtiments notamment par
l'introduction d'un suramment
bénéficiant aux entreprises il nous faut
également lever les contraintes
réglementaires et techniques qui peuvent
limiter l'installation d'ouvrages
renouvelables sur les bâtiments c'est
pourquoi nous avons proposé de rendre
les bâtiments neufs solarisables
c'est-à-dire prêt à accueillir des
énergies renouvelables en descend la
porte ouverte à toutes les nombreuses
par nos entreprises nos startups qui
travaillent sur ces sujets dans un
quatrième et dernier axe nous avons
enfin souhaité sécuriser juridiquement
les porteurs de projets et les autorités
administratives compétentes en matière
de projet d'énergie renouvelable
en la matière nous ajoute son diverses
et nombreux je citerai par exemple les
améliorations apportées à l'article 4
afin de garantir l'effectivité de la
reconnaissance de réseau impérative
d'intérêt public majeurs car l’état du
texte initial cette reconnaissance ne
pouvait concerner que les plus gros
projets d'énergie renouvelables alors
que nous devons entrer dans une logique
décentralisée et dans une logique
d'autoconsommation en résumé ces apports
de bon sens s'appuient sur le ressort
d'une plus grande intelligence
collective et le souci de mieux prendre
en compte les réalités du terrain ou des
terrains formons le vœu que le travail
en sciences publiques nous permettent de
poursuivre dans cette voie merci de
votre attention
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur et
comme chacun a pu l'observer les temps
sont
normaux clairs si chacun pouvait s'y
tenir pour la suite ce serait parfait la
parole est maintenant Monsieur Patrick
Chauvet rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires économiques pour
5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tout d'abord
permettez-moi parce que l'action
publique n'est pas que le fait des élus
de saluer le l'excellent travail ils
sont reconnaîtront d'accès d'Alexis et
Coralie administrateur aux affaires
économiques nous examinons aujourd'hui
le projet de loi d'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable
compétente en matière d'énergie et
d'urbanisme notre commission à veiller
aux aspects économiques de ce texte elle
a reçu une délégation en délégation les
articles 3 16 et les titres Cat et 5 et
c'est saisi pour avis des autres
dispositions au cours de mes travaux
j'ai entendu 45 organismes sans
personnalité et reçu 75 contributions
leur constat est convergent l'objectif
du texte est partagé mais la méthode
critiquée
nous déplorons ainsi un mauvais
séquençage il aurait fallu commencer par
la loi quinquennale sur l'énergie puis
examiner celle sur le nucléaire et enfin
celle sur le renouvelable
nous regrettons aussi
une évaluation parcellaire on propose de
modifier la facture d'énergie des
Français sans études d'impact exhaustive
nous dénonçons également une
concertation limitée les élus locaux
comme les professionnels nous l'ont dit
enfin certaines mesures sont sous
calibrées alors que la France a souscrit
au plan européen visant à porter les
hernies les énergies renouvelables à 45%
d'ici 2030 rien ne garantit que cet
objectif soit atteint
face à la crise énergétique nous sommes
convaincus de la nécessité d'accélérer
l'essor des projets d'énergie
renouvelables aux côtés de la relance de
la filière nucléaire et de l'effort de
sobriété énergétique pour renforcer
notre transition et notre souveraineté
énergétique dans ce contexte notre
commission à agit selon trois axes le
premier axe est de garantir la
neutralité technologique entre les
différentes sources d'énergie
décarbonées en comblant les angles morts
du texte sur l'hydroélectricité la
Commission à facilité les augmentations
de puissance consolider les concessions
échues ajustez les débits minimaux et
simplifier les comités de suivi
sur l'hydrogène elle a intégré les
conclusions de sa mission d'information
sur le sujet sur le biogaz à la créer
des contrats d'achat de long terme
conforter les contrats d'expérimentation
simplifier les autorisations d'urbanisme
faciliter les raccordements et instituer
des opérations d'auto-consommation sur
l'agrivoltaïsme elle a repris une
extension la proposition sur
l'agrivoltaïs adoptée par le Sénat par
251 voies pour et 3 contre le 20 octobre
dernier autre point la Commission a
renforcé le critère du bilan carbone
conditionnant les soutiens publics au
projet d'énergie renouvelable pour
prendre en compte les métaux
stratégiques et englober l'hydrogène le
deuxième axe est d'accélérer les
énergies les énergies renouvelables par
l'organisation de l'État la
simplification des normes le financement
des projets et la résolution des litiges
sur l'article 6 nous avons encadré à
légiférer par ordonnance pour qu'elle
n'induise pas une érosion des
compétences des collectivités une hausse
des coûts des raccordements ou une
déstabilisation des rabais pour les
producteurs d'énergie renouvelables et
les consommateurs électro-intensifs de
plus nous avons inscrit deux
dispositions en dur la suppression d'une
contribution locale et l'attribution
d'une compétence à la creux sur
l'article 18 nous avons ainsi réécrit le
dispositif de partage territorial de la
valeur pour prévoir que le reversement
soit public et collectif et non privé et
individuels en effet le contraire aurait
été complexe à mettre en œuvre et
attentatoire aux principes de
péréquation tarifaire qui garantit un
prix égal de l'électricité ce sont donc
les communes et leurs groupements qui
bénéficieront de ce versement charge à
eux de leur redistribuer ils devront
rendre compte de son montant et de
l'allocation de plus nous avons créé une
contribution
des appels d'offres enfin nous avons
prévu que les communes et leurs
groupements puissent entrer facilement
au capital des sociétés d'énergie
renouvelables le dernier axe est associé
les collectivités en respectant leurs
compétences et leur finances et en
décentralisant les procédures sur
l'article 3 nous avons supprimé la
possibilité pour l'état de modifier
unilatéralement les documents
d'urbanisme et au contraire fournit de
nouveaux outils aux élus locaux
modifications simplifiées des scottes
amélioration de la planification locale
articulations avec Lausanne sur
l'article 16 permettant d'implanter des
ouvrages de raccordement en zone
littorale nous avons prévu la vie des
communes ou de leur groupement la
priorité donnée à l'enfouissement et
l'articulation avec Lausanne au total
nous avons infléchi et enrichit le texte
en gardant toujours à l'esprit deux
impératifs la simplification des normes
cruciale pour les producteurs d'énergie
renouvelables et la territorialisation
des projets nécessaire alors insertion
locale donc alors acceptation sociale
la parole est maintenant madame Laurence
Garnier rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication pour 5 minutes
également
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
la commission de la culture a été saisie
pour avis sur le projet de loi visant à
accélérer le développement des énergies
renouvelables et permettez-moi à mon
tour de saluer Aurore bacille
administratrice qui m'a accompagné dans
le travail mené par la commission au
travers de notre rapport nous avons
d'abord souhaité affirmer notre
conviction que la transition énergétique
ne pourra se faire qu'en cherchant
toujours à conjuguer et jamais à opposer
développement des EnR et préservation du
patrimoine et du cadre de vie des
Français la Commission se réjouit donc
des modifications apportées par la
commission du développement durable pour
permettre aux conseils municipaux
d'accepter ou de refuser un projet de NR
les mers et les élus locaux étant les
premiers garants du cadre de vie des
habitants l'article 1er C introduit à
l'initiative conjointe du rapporteur
Didier Mandelli et de la commission
culture nous paraît donc essentiel
nous regrettons en revanche
l'introduction dans le texte de
disposition qui fragilise la protection
du patrimoine l'article 11 quinquièces
autorise ainsi des dérogations à la vie
conforme de l'ABF pour l'installation de
panneaux fautevotaïques aux abords des
monuments historiques nous savons que
les décisions des ABS peuvent parfois
susciter l'incompréhension des élus
locaux toutefois cette mesure nous
apparaît dangereuse pour le cadre de vie
et l'attractivité touristique de nos
territoires sans apporter de gains
significatifs en termes de NR je
rappelle que la vie conforme de l'ADF ne
concerne aujourd'hui que 6% du
territoire national et que même sur ces
6%, les avis négatifs des ABS dépasse à
peine les 10%. cette mesure nous semble
donc de nature à abîmer nos paysages
pour un gain énergétique purement
symbolique
c'est pourquoi je vous appelle à voter
l'amendement de suppression que j'ai
déposé
[Musique]
dans d'autres cas au contraire les
évolutions technologiques à l'oeuvre
sont au contraire une opportunité pour
préserver nos paysages et je pense à
l'éolien flottant qui doit aujourd'hui
nous permettre d'implanter les parcs
offshore à une plus grande distance de
nos littoraux l'implantation récente du
premier parc éolien en mer au large du
Croisic a suscité beaucoup
d'incompréhensions de la part des élus
locaux soucieuse de préserver nos
littoraux de l'impact visuel et de
l'effet d'encerclement que j'ai moi-même
constaté dans mon département de la
Loire-Atlantique la commission vous
invitera donc à interdire l'implantation
de ces parcs à moins de 40 km des côtes
à compter des prochains appels d'offres
personne ici ne conteste le
développement des EnR et leur nécessité
pour faire face aux enjeux d'écologie et
de souveraineté énergétiques mais
veillons aussi à ce que leur déploiement
ne constitue pas un nouveau motif de
fracture et de division sociale et
territoriale
alors que les éoliennes terrestres se
développent aujourd'hui souvent en
milieu rural et souvent en milieu rural
pauvre une étude qui date de 2019 a
montré que les manifestants pour le
climat étaient majoritairement jeune
urbain et issus de classe sociale
privilégiées si l'on veut mes chers
collègues que les enjeux écologiques ne
soient pas portés uniquement par
quelques-uns mais bien partager par tous
les Français nous devons tracer cette
ligne de crête et trouver le bon
équilibre entre NR et cadre de vie
reprenons discours de Malraux qui
défendait sa loi en 1962 et qui
imaginait des quais de scène livrées
sans règles au promoteur
malrodisez si nous laissions détruire
ces vieux quais de la scène semblables à
des lithographie romantique il
semblerait que nous chassions le génie
de Daumier et l'ombre de Baudelaire
n'oublions pas que nos prédécesseurs ont
su préserver et protéger ce patrimoine
français qui a fait de notre pays la
première destination mondiale notre
responsabilité est donc bien aujourd'hui
de conjuguer développement des énergies
renouvelables avec les enjeux
économiques et touristiques territoriaux
et sociaux pour que notre pays soit au
rendez-vous de toutes ces ambitions
merci
bien dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre corbiset pour le groupe RDS
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
malgré la demande de Monsieur corbiset
il y a pas d'équilibre monsieur mandeli
nous ayant laissé une minute trente je
ne le distribue pas sur les autres
merci dommage oui tout à fait monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre même ma
présidente monsieur le Président de
commissions madame messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues tout
d'abord au nom de mes collègues membres
de la commission aménagement du
territoire permettez-moi d'avoir de
remercier mon collègue Didier mandeli
non seulement pour le travail effectué
mais aussi pour avoir ouvert l'ensemble
de ces auditions à tous les collègues
qui le souhaitaient chers collègues il y
a très exactement une semaine nous
débatturons de la politique énergétique
de l'État dont le présent projet de loi
constitue l'une des déclinaisons
opérationnelles si j'osais la métaphore
culinaire je dirais que dans le menu que
nous a proposé le chef de l'État lors de
son discours de Belfort le projet de loi
initial tel qu'il nous est soumis
apparaît comme une recette bien allégée
et qui manque cruellement d'ingrédients
le sujet aurait mérité une approche
globale et je suis convaincu qu'un temps
de maturation plus long aurait permis
d'aboutir un texte plus cohérent
intégrant l'ensemble des énergies
renouvelables je pense à l'hydrogène à
l'hydroélectricité cher à Monsieur Grimm
mon collègue gremier au gaz vert à la
grivevoltaïsme ou encore l'énergie
marémotrice sous la grivevoltaïsme nous
comprenons mal dans notre groupe que
l'amendement de notre collègue Nathalie
Delattre proposant d'intégrer les fermes
pédagogiques au dispositif était
déclarés irrecevables au petit de
l'Arctique 40 franchement mes chers
collègues refusé un investissement de
panneaux photovoltaïques sur les
bâtiments d'établissement scolaires
agricole qui non seulement produit
l'énergie mais aussi de surcroît
pédagogique pour ses futurs jeunes
agriculteurs brandir à l'article 40
c'était vraiment abusé le travail de nos
deux commissions a fort heureusement pu
enrichir le texte et je me félicite en
particulier des avancées concernant
l'hydrogène renouvelable ou bas carbone
nous aurons à débattre encore et je sais
que nombre de nos collègues ont déposé
des amendements sur cette question
globalité aussi dans l'approche de la
question énergétique elle-même alléger
les contrats administratives pour
accélérer les projets d'une chose mais
il nous faut aussi créer les conditions
pour réussir cette transition
l'adaptation des réseaux qui doivent
devenir intelligents organisations du
stockage de l'énergie produite qui est
un vrai défi la structuration d'une
véritable filière industrielle la
nécessaire recherche en parallèle d'une
réduction de nos consommations par
l'autonomisation des outils de pilotage
et surtout de nos comportements la
décarbonation de notre économie qui
repose comme vous l'avez dit Madame la
Ministre encore dans notre pays a plus
de 60% sur les énergies fossiles nous ne
pouvons faire l'économie de ces sujets
urgents sans quoi nous manquerions le
tournant de la troisième révolution
industrielle en cours cher aux
prospectiviste Jérémie riffkin sur le
contexte sur le connu du contenu du
texte maintenant je pense qu'il faut
être extrêmement prudent sur les motifs
mis en avant en particulier sur la
question de la lenteur des procédures
c'est un procès récurrent fait un autre
administrations
mais la principale cause dans serait-il
pas le manque de ses moyens humains et
financier nous vivons dans tous au
quotidien dans nos territoires l'État
depuis longtemps c'est désengagé les
effectifs des directions départementales
au fond du comme neige au soleil et nos
services déconcentrés sont bien souvent
en pleine sèche mais madame la ministre
vous avez heureusement
rassuré sur cette thématique dans le
même temps le texte doit restaurer la
légitime place des collectivités elles
sont au côté des habitants les premières
concernées par les impacts des nouvelles
installations comme l'a dit très
justement madame la ministre en charge
des collectivités interrogées sur les
ânes elles sont les mieux placées pour
évaluer leurs besoins leur contrainte et
pour chaque dispositif ce sont les
principes d'adaptation de planification
de programmation de territorialisation
qui doivent s'imposer là aussi notre
commission à d'ores et déjà améliorer le
texte mais il ne faut aller plus loin
aussi je salue les dispositions du
projet de loi qui visent à créer un
partage territorial de la valeur des
énergies renouvelables ou imposées aux
sociétés de projets de proposer des pas
aux résidents et aux collectivités
cependant la très grande majorité de mon
groupe s'opposera aux droits de veto des
collectivités sur les projets
d'installation d'éolien terrestre du
biogaz et de photovoltaïque ainsi qu'à
la distance minimale des 40 km des côtes
en matière d'éolien en mer de manière
générale parce que les enjeux pour les
générations futures sont colossaux nous
devons s'agit de la question de la
simplification des procédures faire
preuve de responsabilité de lucidité
trouver le juste équilibre entre la
préservation de notre environnement et
la nécessité d'accélérer notre
transition énergétique sans céder à
l'arbitraire ni aux pression de ce point
de vue je reste convaincu plus que
jamais que les principes de
proportionnalité et de réalisme doivent
nous guider je prendrai un seul exemple
désolé celui de l'amendement relatif à
la suppression de la vie conforme des
ABS pour l'installation de panneaux
solaires sur les toits des habitations
en proximité de sites classées une
avancée bienvenue sachant préserver
notre patrimoine mais soyons aussi
raisonnable vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues notre groupe adoptera
une attitude très constructif sur ce
texte tout en restant attentif aux
impératifs de démocratie participative
et aux enjeux de la préservation de
richesse naturelle je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Madame Martha pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mesdames madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues depuis
plusieurs mois nos concitoyens regardent
avec inquiétude leur facture d'énergie
il se questionne et s'inquiète car
autour de nous en Europe les compteurs
s'affolent l'électricité est en os de 80
% au Royaume-Uni 55 en Belgique en
Belgique 45 au Pays-Bas une seule
réponse produire plus une électricité
abondante disponible et bon marché voilà
la réponse que les Français attendent à
défaut d'être la réponse attendue ce
texte a le mérite d'être une réponse les
vertus environnementales du renouvelable
ne sont plus à démontrer et aide la
France à tenir ses engagements
internationaux en matière d'émission je
salue la volonté du gouvernement
d'amplifier notre production d'énergie
bas carbone il était temps c'est un
chemin qui je l'espère augurera d'autres
déclics un regret malgré tout celui
d'une politique énergétique subie et non
choisie au coup par coup un
[Musique]
le grand carénage ou encore échoué à
pérenniser les EPR
avons-nous fait de notre indépendance
énergétique qui garantissait à la France
une énergie abondante disponible et bon
marché aujourd'hui c'est sur le charbon
que nous comptons pour compenser nos
réacteurs arrêtés et sur le gaz que nous
concitoyens compte pour espérer se
chauffer alors évidemment faisons en
sorte que demain nous puissions
pleinement compter sur le secteur du
renouvelable dans le mix énergétique
français mais madame la ministre combien
de kilomètres carrés de champ
photovoltaïques combien de kilomètres de
côtes garnie d'éolienne en mer
faudra-t-il pour répondre aux besoins de
la France et quelles précaution
devons-nous prendre en matière
environnementale et de souveraineté
énergétique telle doit être la
contribution de ce texte au grand enjeux
énergétique de demain tel et son
ambition et je la prouve pourtant il est
Lude certains sujets essentiels
accélérez la production des ENR signifie
leur déploiement massif partout dans les
territoires s'interroger sur leur impact
environnemental et économique salutaire
et crucial soyons lucides les déployés
sans discernement ni quelques
précautions signifient et financées une
industrie venue d'ailleurs constat
regrettable mais que chacun connaît les
géants industriels de cette filière sont
aujourd'hui principalement chinois pour
le photovoltaïque danois et allemand
pour léolien et l'éolien en mer je
souhaite en effet que les entreprises
français se saisissent de ces
opportunités environnementales
économique que le texte laisse entrevoir
et veillons madame la ministre à ce que
dans les différents plans
d'investissement d'avenir et plan France
2030 nous encourageions les initiatives
françaises et que nous les soutenions ne
réitérons pas les erreurs du passé nous
n'avons pas su créer une filière
industrielle française d'équipements
compétitifs et vertueux sur tout leur
cycle de vie les traitements des déchets
et le recyclage sont également un enjeu
impératif des équipements démantelés
accélérer aujourd'hui les implantations
c'est demain de voir en subir le coût
environnement frontal avec tout ce que
cela comporte en termes de traitement et
de valorisation des déchets pour le
photovoltaïque une filière REP ces
structurée ce qui n'est pas à ce jour le
cas pour l'éolien l'échéance est
pourtant déjà là car d'ici 2025 les
premières générations d'éoliennes
devront être démantelés selon l'ADEME la
masse du néolienne est recyclable à
90%, l'essentiel de la masse est dans
ses fondations et des filières existent
en effet pour les fondations mais ce
n'est pas le cas pour tous les
composants comme les pales par exemple
or si nous accélérons le déploiement des
éoliennes il est impératif d'anticiper
le traitement de tous les déchets
issus de leur démantèlement anticipons
dès maintenant ayant une vision d'avenir
à 30 ans sur l'ensemble du cycle de vie
des éoliennes implantées dans un souci
d'économie circulaire je me réjouis de
l'adoption commission de mon amendement
visant à créer une filière REP ou tout
système équivalent de prévention et de
des déchets pour l’éolien avant de
conclure je souhaite aussi remercier
notre rapporteur Didier mandeli pour son
écoute tout au long de l'examen du texte
et pour tout le travail effectué au sein
de notre commission ce texte enrichit
par l'apport de tous les commissaires va
son mauvais jeu de mots de ma part
libéré des énergies pour un secteur qui
ne demande qu'à se développer mais pour
que le déploiement soit ambitieux
accepté dans nos territoires madame la
ministre il faudra tenir compte de
l'ensemble des enjeux importants je vous
merci à chacun de respecter les temps je
rappelle que il y a 573 amendements si
chacun déborde moi ça m'est égal je
préside samedi après-midi mais bon allez
la parole est il a bien fait de monter
tout de suite à Monsieur Pierre
metvielle pour les indépendants pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs chers collègues
la guerre en Ukraine ses conséquences
géopolitiques et économiques ont
bouleversé l'esprits d'approvisionnement
des produits énergétiques fossiles
rappelant la dépendance de notre
économie et de nos modes de vie aux
énergies importées cette situation
constitue un nouveau paradigme dont il
nous faut prendre acte
dans ce contexte le gouvernement a
présenté ce projet de loi et en vocation
à répondre rapidement et efficacement au
défi énergétique que nous aurons à
relever dans les années à venir c'est un
signal politique fort
je tiens d'abord à saluer l'oreille très
attentive du gouvernement dans la phase
de préparation de ce texte mais aussi le
travail effectué au sein de chaque
commission qui a notamment permis
l'adoption de plusieurs amendements
déposés par des sénateurs de notre
groupe sur des points essentiels
vous le savez le groupe Les Indépendants
soutient une écologie libérale
pragmatique et pertinente nous devons
absolument aller vers une simplification
en matière de déploiement des
dispositifs générateur d'énergie
renouvelable ici simplifier implique de
réduire le temps de développement
d'énergie renouvelables pour accélérer
leur déploiement sur nos territoires
simplifier inclut également de libérer
des énergies et des technologies
nouvelles pour gagner en souveraineté
notamment grâce à la production de nrba
carbone ces dernières constituent selon
moi une pierre angulaire de notre mix
énergétique qui à terme dont nous
permettre d'assurer notre alimentation
en électricité tout en préservant notre
environnement
par ailleurs si le projet de loi
actuelle couvre un large spectre de
solutions énergétiques il a dû être
complété afin d'y inclure l'hydrogène la
géothermie ou la grivevoltaïsme en effet
il me semble essentiel que la
grivevoltaïsme puisse figuré dans ce
texte au sein de sandwich parlementaire
du 20 octobre dernier le groupe Les
Indépendants a porté et fait adopter une
proposition de loi visant à encadrer le
développement de ces pratiques
ces mesures ont pu être insérées dans le
texte dès l'examen en commission j'en
profite pour remercier les auteurs des
différents amendements déposés la grille
voltaïsme n'importe tout
particulièrement puisque rappelons-le
ces bénéfices sont multiples il permet à
nos agriculteurs d'avoir un revenu
complémentaire tout en garantissant la
primauté de l'activité agricole
il représente également une nouvelle
source de production énergétique sans
aggraver l'artificialisation des sols
points essentiels qui est revenu dans
nos débat
certes je viens d'évoquer des avancées
tout à fait notables pour autant le
travail doit se poursuivre je suis
convaincu que nous devons penser notre
transition dans une architecture plus
large c'est pourquoi les autres textes
annoncés dès le début de l'année
prochaine me semble indispensable afin
de poursuivre nos objectifs vers
davantage d'indépendance énergétique
parmi ces textes je pense à la
programmation employée annuelle de
l'énergie ou encore au projet de loi sur
le nucléaire énergies qui restera
essentielle dans notre mix énergétique
décarbonée
rappelons également l'importance du
stockage des ENR question absente
jusqu'ici le stockage de ces énergies
dit intermittentes présentes un
potentiel important notamment grâce à la
technique du power to gosse qui pour le
dire plus simplement tient à transformer
les unr en hydrogène une dernière
problématique me tient à cœur il s'agit
de la place des collectivités locales et
des élus locaux dans le développement
des EnR je suis convaincu du rôle qu'ils
ont à jouer en la matière mais je crois
aussi à l'importance de trouver un
équilibre juste entre un droit de veto
qui le serait octroyer pour
l'installation de projet ENR et
l'impératif de développement des
énergies renouvelables et bas carbone la
question peut paraître clivante mais nos
besoins énergétiques immédiats sont une
réalité ils ne peuvent souffrir d'un
droit de blocage qui serait souvent
arbitraire
de même je ne suis pas du tout perçu à
des que l'octroi des autorisations en
matière de dispositif d'énergie
renouvelable au seul maire serait le
rendre service il se retrouve ré dans
tous les cas seuls sous une autre forte
pression voir le communiqué national de
la RF
à travers ce texte nous devons
privilégier le sens de l'intérêt
collectif et maître de côté les intérêts
politiques partisans
en matière d'énergie renouvelable le
meilleur reste à venir je pense par
exemple au projet d'Airbus différentes
space toulousain solar BIM centrale
photovoltaïque spatiale qui pourra
alimenter les avions en vol par faisceau
notre indépendance énergétique dépendra
également de notre audace de notre
ambition et des futurs progrès
technologiques notre groupe Les
Indépendants votre en faveur de ce
projet de loi pour soutenir l'effort
commun vers une transition durable et
vers davantage de s'ouvrir unités
énergétiques
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Renan Dantec pour le
groupe écologiste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Monsieur et Madame les rapporteurs
monsieur le président de commission
chers collègues enfin enfin l'État
reconnaît que face à la très grave crise
énergétique que nous vivons nous n'avons
qu'une seule solution le développement
rapide et massif des énergies
renouvelables notamment pour la
production d'électricité enfin les
scènes lois arrivent malheureusement
bien tard presque 8 ans après que la loi
relative à la transition énergétique
pour la croissance verte est déjà fixée
à l'horizon 2025 le rééquilibrage du mix
énergétique français entre le nucléaire
et les énergies renouvelables huit ans
c'est un temps suffisant pour développer
une réelle stratégie territoriale et
industrielle mettre en cohérence dans
les politiques publiques les objectifs
fixés par la loi mais force est de
constater que ce temps a été gaspillé
pour des donc je me régale le temps de
développer et au détriment donc de notre
économie et du pouvoir d'achat des
Françaises et des Français nous sommes
aujourd'hui le seul pays européen à ne
pas tenir les objectifs de développement
des énergies renouvelables prévues dans
la directive cadre de 2009 en urgence
donc le gouvernement nous dit son
intérêt son empressement pour les
énergies renouvelables que Madame la
minif a qualifié hier matin sur une
grande radio nationale je la sais
d'ultra compétitive rejoins donc par
l'État dans l'analyse que notre salut
passe par les énergies renouvelables une
question de survie a aussi dit madame la
Première ministre le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire accueille donc
évidemment favorablement cette loi mais
car il y a un mais s'interroge quand
même un peu sur son efficience premier
point le retard du développement des
énergies renouvelables est d'abord
actuellement liée au prix trop bas
proposé par la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie
qui ne permettent pas le succès complet
des appels d'offres si clairement les
énergies renouvelables produisent
aujourd'hui l'électricité la moins chère
les tarifs proposés sont néanmoins trop
bas j'entends bien sûr madame la mise
votre préoccupation de ne pas créer de
super profits injustifié pour les
entreprises du secteur surtout que vous
vous interdiriez en plus de les retacher
après mais même avec quelques euros de
plus sur ce prix les énergies
renouvelables resteront de loin les
moins chers ensuite la deuxième raison
du retard est liée à la prudence des
investisseurs qui attendent que tous les
recours même les non suspensifs soient
expurgés sur ce point l'amendement du
rapport de la du rapporteur de la
commission du développement durable dont
je salue moi aussi l'engagement sur ce
texte à très opportunément ouvert à la
création d'un Fonds de Garantie
mutualisant les risques liés au recours
contentieux c'est probablement le
dispositif qui nous permettra de gagner
le plus de temps dans la mise en œuvre
des projets ainsi les gars espérer sur
les simplifications administratives qui
sont le socle du texte apparaissent
assez secondaire par rapport au point
que je viens d'évoquer le groupe
écologiste est très vigilant sur le fait
que ce texte ne détricote pas le droit
de l'environnement et ne s'applique pas
en dehors du sujet des énergies
renouvelables et n'affaiblissent donc
pas le nom régression du droit de
l'environnement le gouvernement a
entendu la vie très négatif et ferme du
Conseil national de la transition
écologique et le texte a été modifié
dans le bon sens depuis sa première
présentation certains points restent
néanmoins problématiques notamment sur
les enjeux de biodiversité nous y
reviendrons durant le débat en séance
enfin reste les lignes rouges
allègrement franchies par la majorité
sénatoriale qui a fait de ce projet de
loi un texte de ralentissement plus que
d'accélération le droit de veto des mers
pour des projets qualifiés par ailleurs
comme relevant de l'intérêt général
c'est assez étonnant voire même de
l'ordre de l'oxymore c'est d'ailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs un revirement
historique de la part d'un mouvement aux
racines gaullistes et jacobine toujours
fier de mettre en avant les épopées
industrielles du pont pidolyse ici c'est
donc l'inverse l'intérêt national
s'efface face aux enjeux locaux c'est
une première qui ouvrira demain la porte
à l'interdiction par décision locale ici
d'un bout de ligne de TGV et pourquoi
pas là-bas d'un petit réacteur nucléaire
ça va devenir ça va devenir très
compliqué
pour devenir très compliqué
une stratégie nationale de même plus
vous interrompez plus je vais lui donner
du temps de parole alors bon ça va pas
le faire
allez allez on se calme chacun ça va
donc devenir très compliqué d'avoir une
stratégie nationale
interdit le développement sur la
majorité du littoral je veux bien qu'un
léger un confort pour des propriétaires
de résidence secondaire avec vue sur mer
soit plus important que l'avenir de
notre industrie et la facture
énergétique des Français et Françaises
mais je m'interroge quand même sur le
sens de certaines priorités le maintien
de ces deux barrières va rendre
évidemment ce texte novotable en l'état
pour le groupe écologiste mais nous
espérons néanmoins que le bon sens
collectif l'emportera durant les débats
en séance merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant madame Nadège
avait pour le groupe RDPI pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mandeli madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis mes chers collègues notre maison
brûle et nous l'avons vu concrètement
cet été avec 66000 hectares parti en
fumée en Gironde dans les Landes et même
dans le Finistère le mois d'octobre
c'est qui s'est achevé aura été le plus
chaud de notre histoire face à cette
réalité à cette menace d'un
réchauffement climatique de près de 3
degrés l'ONU il y a quelques jours
rappelait que l'unique option était la
transformation rapide
urgente de nos sociétés à l'occasion du
lancement du Conseil national de
refondation climat et biodiversité la
première ministre a également alerté sur
la radicalité des changements à
effectuer afin de franchir la marche
avec cet objectif d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone en milieu de siècle
le défi à relever est colossal et la
fenêtre d'opportunité est en train de se
refermer à plus court terme face à des
circuits d'approvisionnement pétrole et
gaz Mia mal la guerre en Ukraine il est
aussi nécessaire d'activer tous les
leviers il nous faut en effet développer
toutes les sources d'énergie décarbonées
notamment renouvelables en particulier
l'éolien le photovoltaïque ou encore la
méthanisation il nous faut accélérer une
nécessité alors que notre pays il est
vrai est en retard en 2020 la part de
ses énergies dans la consommation finale
brute est d'environ 19%, 3 points de
moins que la moyenne dans l'Union
européenne sur la base de ce constat ce
texte constitue une réponse à laquelle
il faut ajouter bien entendu l'entretien
et le développement de notre parc
nucléaire pour défendre notre
souveraineté maîtriser les coûts et
atteindre la neutralité carbone il y a
une semaine notre commission a adopter
129 amendements et je veux ici saluer
l'engagement sur ce texte de notre
rapporteur Didier mandeli qui nous a
permis d'assister aux auditions ainsi
que celle de la ministre madame la
ministre pour votre écoute
le Titre 1 du projet de loi entend
apporter des mesures d'urgence notamment
procédurales pour accélérer les projets
d'énergie renouvelables et industrielle
notre commission a pu ajouter et
préciser des dispositions utiles à ses
premiers articles je pense notamment à
la désignation des référents
préfectoraux dans chaque département
pour l'instruction des autorisations
relatives au projet de NR d'autres
modifications ne nous conviennent pas et
j'y reviendrai afin d'accélérer le
développement de l'énergie solaire qui
est l'objet du titre suivant le texte
rend notamment possible l'installation
de ces ouvrages aux abords des
autoroutes et routes à grande
circulation il nous faudra également le
faire aux abords des voies ferrées un
travail d'inventaire est en cours par
ailleurs lorsque nous avions débattu de
votre proposition de loi monsieur le
rapporteur en février dernier j'avais
rappelé la nécessité d'offrir à nos élus
locaux situés en zone littorale un cadre
juridique protecteur mais adapté aux
enjeux contemporains c'est dans cette
logique que je soutiendrai en séance
plusieurs amendements déposés sur
l'article 9 nous avons également fait
adopter en commission une dérogation sur
le modèle des antennes relais dans la
loi élan afin que soit demandé un avis
simple de l'architecte des bâtiments de
France pour un projet d'installation à
des fins d'auto-consommation sur les
bâtiments situés en zone classée avec
des conditions précisées par des craies
je m'en expliquerai lors des échanges à
venir mais j'ai eu de très bons retours
des élus de mon territoire sur cette
proposition il s'agit de la même
philosophie pour l'agrivoltaïsme qui
constitue une grande réserve de fonciers
si la pratique est faite de manière
régulière sans mettre en cause
l'activité agricole à ce propos mon
groupe tient à remercier nos collègues
pour leur travail qui a aboutit à une
proposition de loi équilibrée et
raisonnée adopter il y a deux semaines
dont les dispositions ont été
introduites dans le texte sur le
développement d'éolien en mer ensuite
dans le pacte signé il y a quelques mois
l'État a confirmé sa volonté d'un
déploiement ambitieux avec un objectif
d'attribution de 40 GW d'ici
la filière s'est engagée quant à elle à
quadrupler le nombre d'emplois directs
et indirects liés à l'éolien en mer
d'ici 2035 et engagé plus de 40
milliards d'euros d'investissement en 15
ans une filière structurée donc en forte
croissance mais qui a besoin de
visibilité planification et nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir pendant les
débats c'est une filière qui a aussi
besoin d'être conforté aussi nous
voterons contre le seuil des 40 km cela
reviendrait sur la Côte d'Opale à ne
pouvoir en faire du tout ou alors sur le
territoire britannique plus sérieusement
une telle distance au large de nos
littoraux serait contraire à une
planification territoriale équilibrée de
cette énergie aussi sur l'éolien
terrestre nous avions trouvé un juste
équilibre à l'issue de l'examen de la
loi 3DS or ce qui a été voté en
commission revient à donner un coup
d'arrêt au projet de construction des
d'exploitation que des concertations
locales et lieu évidemment et nous
soutenons que les élus locaux puissent
intervenir sur des projets
d'implantation dans le cadre un échange
encadré avec le porteur de projet mais
nous sommes opposés au droit de veto
tels que définis position partagée
notamment par l'Association des maires
de ruraux de France dans leur
communiquée de presse du 2 novembre
parmi les deux les dispositions
relatives au financement et aux partages
de la valeur il nous est apparu
nécessaire de soutenir des mesures
d'appropriation et des modèles de
financement locaux au service des
territoires c'est pourquoi nous avons
déposé un environnement qui a fait objet
de faciliter le développement de
l'autoconsommation de gaz renouvelables
c'est dans ce même esprit d'efficacité
de diversification que nous avons déposé
un amendement de séance pour que les
acheteurs publics puissent recouvrir en
toute sécurité juridique au nouveau mode
de commercialisation de l'électricité
d'origine renouvelable que sont
l'autoconsommation les contrats d'achat
d'électricité renouvelable ce sont des
mesures facilitatrices mais simples qui
pourront s'avérer très utiles pour nos
collectivités et nos PME en conclusion
notre groupe suivra toute proposition
des idées qui peuvent soutenir et
renforcer le développement des énergies
décarbonées et à contrario ne nous
opposerons à toutes celles défensives
qui a un truc qui traduiront par une
décélération je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et
maintenant monsieur Jean-Michel Houlgate
pour le groupe socialiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
Madame et Monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues tout le monde s'accorde
à dire que nous devons accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
en particulier pour faire face à la
demande croissante en électricité qui
viendra à se substituer notamment dans
les transports et l'industrie aux
énergies fossiles rappelons tout de même
que notre production actuelle
d'électricité grâce à son mix
énergétique et faiblement carboné la
crise énergétique les liée à l'agression
de l'Ukraine par la Russie nous fait
mesurer combien il est urgent d'agir et
peut-être regretté que les grandes
orientations stratégiques et la
planification qui en découle n'est pas
été anticipée au cours du précédent
quinquennat ce projet de loi est certes
le bienvenu mais il aura été plus
logique de procéder de façon rationnelle
en élaborant de façon concertée la
stratégie française pour l'énergie le
climat une stratégie globale comprenant
certes la production mais aussi la la
variété l'efficacité énergétique avec
l'intensification des procédés
industriels mais aussi l'isolation
thermique des bâtiments puis enfin la
captation par les puits carbone tout
cela nous est annoncé pour 2023 avec une
loi de programmation pour l'énergie le
climat ainsi qu'une troisième PPE qui
couvrira à les périodes 2024 2033 ainsi
aussi qu'une troisième stratégie
nationale bas carbone et enfin un plan
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique alors dans ce contexte nous
devons analyser ce projet de loi avec
pragmatisme en essayant d'anticiper tout
ce qui peut l'être et en posant des
accroches qui pourront servir d'appui à
la future stratégie en ayant pour
boussole le principe que l'accélération
ne doit pas se faire ni au détriment de
la concertation ni au détriment de
l'environnement la concertation et les
procédures qui en découlent sont souvent
perçus comme un boulet qui freine les
projets alors qu'au contraire la
concertation en amont plus elle associe
la population et les élus plus alors les
projets sont facilités la concertation
fluidifie les procédures son absence les
crises et les grilles le rapport du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental acceptabilité des
nouvelles infrastructures de transition
énergétique transition subie transition
choisie est éloquent dans ce domaine le
texte qui nous est soumis a été
profondément remodelés par les
commissions sénatoriales et je dois moi
aussi souligner l'implication des
rapporteurs et c'est très écriture
comporte de nombreux avancées avec
l'introduction d'une planification
territoriale même si l'on doit se poser
la question de l'échelle pertinente et
de la méthode la mise en place d'une
concertation préalable systématique la
désignation d'un référent départemental
préfigurant un guichet unique mais qui
renvoie au moyen dont l'état dispose
pour instruire et accompagner les
projets la création d'un Fonds de
Garantie l'extension a de nombreux
bâtiments de l'intégration d'un procédé
de production d'énergie renouvelable sur
une surface de leur toiture la
prévention des pratiques de dumping
social sur les navires dans les parcs
éoliennes en mer la création d'un
mécanisme de suramortissement et enfin
la mise en place d'un nouveau dispositif
de partage de la valeur
mais hélas ce qui a été accordé d'une
main pour faciliter les projets semble
avoir été repris de l'autre en ajoutant
des verrous qui vont compliquer les
déploiements la majorité sénatoriale mue
sans doute par un tropisme vendéen
risque de transformer la vie des
porteurs de projets en épreuve de
Fort-Boyard le rejet implicite
le rejet implicite de l'éolien en mer
au-delà des 40 km condamne l'éolien posé
en Méditerranée il exclut la
quasi-totalité de la mère de la Manche
et de la Mer du Nord et fragilise de
sorte la filière industrielle française
qui s'est implantée en créant des
emplois sur Le Havre Cherbourg et même
Saint-Nazaire car la technologie
française de l'éolien flottant n'est pas
encore arrivé à une totale maturité dans
un autre domaine même si l'on comprend
et partage l'exaspération des élus
locaux à qui l'on a quasiment imposé des
champs d'éolien terrestres il est
légitime de se poser la question s'il
n'y a pas des moyens consensuels basés
sur l'intelligence collective des
territoires pour trouver des solutions
et substituer à la décision individuelle
une décision collégiale je ne doute pas
que ces sujets animeront nos débats et
c'est en fonction de ce texte définitif
et des amendements adoptés que le groupe
que notre groupe déterminera sa position
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Marie-Claude varailla
pour le groupe CRCE pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur dans son
dernier rapport le GIEC alerte sur la
nécessité de réduire de moitié les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 et pour cela
identifie des solutions possibles dans
les domaines de l'énergie des transports
de l'industrie et de l'usage des terres
il insiste néanmoins sur la nécessité
d'une transition juste dans les
inégalités sont flagrantes au niveau
mondial les 10% des plus riches sont à
l'origine de 36 à 45% des émissions
quand les pays les plus pauvres ne sont
responsables que de 3 à 5%. en matière
de déploiement des ENR nous faisons
figure de mauvais élèves puisque nous
sommes le seul pays à ne pas avoir
atteint notre objectif de 23% dans notre
consommation finale d'énergie lorsque
l'on sait que l'objectif est de 33%
l'horizon 2033 si le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste et
favorables au développement des énergies
renouvelables aux côtés de notre mix
énergétique historique d'origine nu et
hydraulique nous considérons cependant
qu’elle ne doivent pas être génératrices
de nouvelles dérégulations et que leur
essor exige la structuration de
véritables filières par la puissance
publique nous savons que la théorie qui
consiste à laisser faire le marché
s'avère extrêmement coûteuse pour les
usagers ce projet de loi en défendant
une accélération intensive des projets
plutôt qu'une planification réfléchie en
amont propose la manière forte avec le
risque de s'avérer contre-productive en
radicalisant les oppositions et en
éloignant les citoyens des enjeux de la
transition énergétique à l'occasion de
la concertation que vous n'avez pas
manqué madame la ministre d'organiser
autour de ce texte nous n'avons pas
manqué aussi nous de vous renvoyer la
voie de nos territoires élus
associations citoyens qui fasse à des
implantations quasi imposées exige
légitimement de prendre toute leur place
en amont des projets le rapport présenté
au nom de la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
par notre collègue rapporteur Didier
Mandelli qui mécanis le projet de loi de
129 en amendement insiste sur les
avancées nécessaires en matière
d'accepter d'acceptabilité et de
planification des projets mais il
demeure cependant dans ce texte les
adaptations de procédures
administratives qui constituent des
reculs démocratiques comme notamment la
consultation des citoyens par la voie
électronique alors que ce sont
précisément les territoires concernés
par ces implantations qui sont les plus
éloignées du numérique à cette égard
d'ailleurs je cite le Conseil économique
social et environnemental qui recommande
d'aller chercher la contribution des
personnes silencieuses et des invisibles
en veillant à prendre en compte
l'électronisme il prône aussi d'ailleurs
aussi l'évaluation en posteriori de la
concrétisation des engagements des
porteurs de projets la procédure
simplifiée de modification des documents
d'urbanisme et de nature elle aussi à
faciliter les atteintes à
l'environnement par ailleurs et vous le
savez madame la ministre ces nouvelles
procédures accélérées ne pour
coefficient tout ça renforcer les moyens
humains des services de l'État comme ne
manque pas d'ailleurs de le relever le
Conseil d'État ce projet de loi défend
un modèle visant décarboner la
production qui selon nous doit aller de
pair avec la notion de sobriété vue sous
l'angle par exemple du soutien transport
collectif dans le ferroviaire et
l'isolation thermique des bâtiments face
au prix de l'énergie face aux attentes
des Françaises et des Français nous
devons être le plus efficace possible 13
millions de familles vivent aujourd'hui
dans ce que l'on appelle des passoires
thermiques et qui souffrent qui souvent
se chauffe dans des conditions
déplorables comme nous le rappelle les
3000 intoxication monoxyde de carbone
qui ont lieu chaque année il y a urgence
à soutenir un grand plan de lutte contre
la précarité énergétique en capacité de
créer des emplois non délocalisables
avec de vrais résultats en termes de
confort et de pouvoir d'achat des
ménages par ailleurs mon groupe ne
soutiendra pas les modèles de
financement hybrides promus ce texte en
matière de partage de la valeur ce
système aboutit à différencier le prix
de l'énergie en fonction de la
localisation des clients et on provenant
ainsi gravement au principe d'égalité
entre les usagers s'il doit y avoir un
retour économique lié à la présence de
ces installations alors il doit revenir
aux collectivités locales qui est qui
elle gère l'intérêt général l'énergie
est un bien commun un droit fondamental
et universel car il permet l'accès aux
droits aux autres droits que sur l'eau
l'accès à l'eau à la santé à l'éducation
à l'emploi à la sécurité à l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes la
libéralisation des marchés de
l'électricité engagée en 1996 a conduit
à l'éclatement du service public de
l'électricité et du gaz les EnR doivent
être sortis des griffes du marché pour
être développées là où elles sont le
plus efficace en ayant pour critères
l'intérêt collectif et celui de la
protection de l'environnement si
effectivement ce projet de loi amendé
dans la commission comporte quelques
avancées notre vote dépendra des débats
et des amendements qui en résulteront je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant madame Denis
Saint-Pé pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
mais si le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le texte que nous
allons examiner aujourd'hui revêt une
importance toute particulière alors que
nous connaissons une crise énergétique
sans précédent à l'heure où le spectre
d'une pénurie d'énergie ressurgies
d'autant plus menaçant que notre parc
nucléaire est pour moitié indisponible
il est en effet plus nécessaire que
jamais d'accélérer notre production
d'énergie renouvelable cela permettrait
d'éviter à nos ménages nos entreprises
et nos collectivités locales de subir
des lestage rationnement ou blackout
tout en garantissant notre souveraineté
énergétique et en s'inscrivant dans la
lutte contre le changement climatique il
ne s'agit pas pour autant de négliger le
nucléaire dont nous nous sommes tous
bien conscients des atouts cependant la
[Musique]
pour ma part j'accueille favorablement
plusieurs propositions de mon collègue
rapporteur Didier mandeli fait en
commission aménagement du territoire et
développement durable je pense par
exemple à la définition à la limitation
de la phase d'examen de la demande
d'autorisation environnementale à 4 mois
ou encore au référent préfectoral à
l'instruction des projets d'énergies
renouvelables et des projets industriels
nécessaires à la transition énergétique
par ailleurs ces amendements visant à
démultiplier les possibilités
d'implantation du photovoltaïque me
semble indispensable pour maximiser le
déploiement de cette énergie cependant
je déplore que certains amendements
votaient en commission mettent en péril
l'édifice que nous avons co-construit
comment pouvons-nous ainsi proposer de
revenir sur le dispositif équilibré de
la loi 3DS sur l'éolien on envisageant
aujourd'hui un veto des élus municipaux
sur les projets d'abord cela ralentirait
la procédure ce qui serait
contre-productif
plus dangereux encore cela mettrait les
projets éoliens terrestres à la merci de
critères politiques et donc subjective
un risque d'autant plus accru si toutes
les communes en covisibilité sont
concernés aussi je ne crois pas
raisonnable ni responsable d'instaurer
un tel dispositif de même comment
soutenir des mesures visant à gêner
l'implantation d'éoliennes offshore à
moins de 40 km des côtes quand dans le
même temps l'éolien flottant qui permet
d'aller au-delà de cette distance n'est
pas encore mature c'est à se demander si
nous avons tous la même conscience de la
gravité du moment en pleine crise
climatique et énergétique mon groupe
n’étant pas uneanime sur ces questions
la vie que j'ai exprime représente celui
d'une partie de mes collègues nous
comptons tous néanmoins sur le débat et
des jours à venir pour que le
gouvernement et le Sénat s'accordent sur
des solutions de compromis
satisfaisantes je vous remercie
la parole
la parole est maintenant Monsieur Daniel
grémillier pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
madame la ministre madame messieurs les
rapporteurs madame la Présidente et
monsieur le Président des deux
commissions mes chers collègues
nous avons un texte qui nous arrive
presque un peu en urgence
et ce texte en urgence je voudrais en
quelques
paroles retracer son histoire
tout a commencé avec le général de
Gaulle lorsqu'il a fait le choix du
nucléaire et de la construction de
l'hydroélectricité
tout a été poursuivi par les présidents
qui se sont succédés que ça soit le prix
d'un Pompidou Giscard d'Estaing même
président Mitterrand qui pendant un
temps avaient hésité était revenu sur
effectivement la nécessité de faire
continuer d'investissement dans le
nucléaire
poursuivi sur le président Chirac
poursuit sous la présidence Sarkozy
pourquoi je évoque cela
c'est que sans le savoir
la France était le premier pays à avoir
une énergie décarbonée pour 85% dès
l'origine dès le départ avec le choix du
nucléaire 75%, 13% sur
l'hydroélectricité je dis parce que
c'est ça la réalité et la réalité c'est
elle va encore plus loin
c'est que cette réalité c'est aussi une
réalité qui a permis aux Français
d'avoir une énergie abondante et
compétitive pour notre économie à
travers tous les territoires
et effectivement
les problèmes et les noms décisions ont
commencé d'abord avec la présidente
Hollande la présidence Macron
qui sous ces deux non mais c'est la
réalité des faits parfois c'est gênant
de l'entendre et la réalité c'est quoi
on a décidé de revenir un parc nucléaire
à 50% au lieu des 75 on a décidé
effectivement fermeture de 15 ans serait
réacteur et dans les 14 il y avait les
deux de Fessenheim où on avait dit on
fermera Fessenheim conflammam en ville
sera en capacité de produire
je continue parce que
non seulement d'avoir décidé cela on a
aussi décidé de
revenir sur
Astrid qui était la quatrième génération
sur les productions nucléaires
et pendant ce temps là
et ça me fait penser un peu à la Cigale
et la Fourmi
parce que non satisfait d'avoir fait
cela
nous avons décidé
d'arrêter la recherche et l'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures sur notre territoire
nous avons décidé
le tout électrique et nous avons décidé
aussi l'interdiction de la fragmentation
l'exploitation de gaz de schiste alors
que d'autres pays font ces choix là
le problème de tout ça d'où ce texte
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu
le en même temps
il n'y a pas eu en même temps parce que
lorsqu'on décide de diminuer la
production énergétique qui nous amène
dans cette précarité que nous
connaissions dans qui nous amène à ses
coûts de l'énergie aussi élevée bien
plus élevée que l'Allemagne nous sommes
à 100 euros de plus que l'Allemagne
c'est du jamais vu
et bien effectivement il n'y a pas eu en
même temps parce que on n'a pas été en
capacité de produire d'autres énergies y
compris renouvelables et madame la
ministre
dans votre déclaration
aux échos
d'hier j'ai bien entendu votre propos et
je voudrais vous dire tout simplement le
débat que nous avons à cet instant
quand je vois des difficultés que nous
avons eu ici
à voter un texte notamment sur le texte
climat résilience qui disait tout
simplement on ne fermera plus de
réacteurs si on n'a pas l'équivalent en
dur de production énergétique c'est on a
eu une difficulté incroyable et je
voudrais dire tout simplement que tous
les travaux du Sénat qui ont été votés
ici c'est pas faute de les avoir dit les
travaux de la commission des affaires
économiques qui étaient de placer en
permanence de revenir de garantir la
souveraineté énergétique de notre pays
accessible à nos concitoyens compétitifs
pour notre économie c'est des tas de
propositions de textes qui ont été votés
par le Sénat sur lesquels vous n'avez
pas entendu notre discours et nos
propositions donc aujourd'hui c'est un
peu une séance de rattrapage parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui en dehors
des capacités de produire cette énergie
nucléaire nouvelle horizons dans 10 ans
il y a urgence à intervenir pour
garantir cette énergie à nos concitoyens
merci merci
merci chers collègues
la parole et maintenant Monsieur Franck
Montauger pour le groupe socialiste pour
4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chère collègue nous l'avons dit lors
d'un récent débat avec le gouvernement
et 5 décès et PPE auraient dû constituer
le point d'entrée de la politique
énergétique de la France au lieu de quoi
nous discutons aujourd'hui sans
connaître vos objectifs précis du
déploiement de certaines énergies
renouvelables demain du nouveau
nucléaire et après-demain peut-être de
l'hydraulique dans ce contexte flou et
pour le moins problématique rarement
projet de loi gouvernementale aura été
autant modifié sur le fond par les
commissions du Sénat et leur rapporteur
que je salue et suite aux nombreuses
observations du Conseil d'État et il
fallait qu'il le soit tant qu'il nous
est apparu comme approximatif et
imprécie sur bien des points et de sur
quoi de surcroît contrevenant aux
libertés les plus fondamentales des élus
locaux
dans la perspective d'intérêt général du
Zéro Carbone en 2050 les sénateurs du
groupe socialiste se sont placés du
point de vue des élus locaux pour
améliorer votre proposition et je
voudrais ici rappeler notre position
ferme à votre proposition d'ingérence
des préfets dans les orientations des
PLU la solution est ailleurs dans le
respect et le dialogue avait les élus
locaux pour faire avancer efficacement
la production d'énergie renouvelable sur
nos territoires il faut définir et
déployer une planification dans le sens
état collectivité territoriale et dans
le sens collectivité territoriale état
nous avons dans la législation tous les
outils pour y parvenir contrat de plan
état région sera dette Scott pcaet et
plu j'ajoute que bon sens et dialogue à
tous les échelons nous permettront
d'être au rendez-vous des objectifs
fixés sur tous les territoires et dans
les délais
pour ce qui est du développement de
l'éolien nous vous ferons des
propositions réalistes imprégnées du
vécu de terrain et de nature à diminuer
l'impact des nuisances par contre nous
pensons que le partage de la valeur doit
s'opérer par l'intermédiaire des
collectivités locales concernées nous
tenons à ce que le principe de
péréquation tarifaire perdure pour tous
les consommateurs et sur l'ensemble du
territoire national loi de Kirchhof
oblige la consommation ne se fait pas
obligatoirement à proximité immédiate du
lieu de production nous tenons aussi à
vous rappeler la nécessité de
restructurer le marché européen et les
tarifs de l'électricité
nous tenons aussi à vous rappeler dans
ce cadre pardon les tarifs réguliers
doivent être maintenus et développés le
texte permet l'accès des collectivités
locales au contrat de long terme type
PPA ils doivent être encadrés afin
d'être protecteur à l'inverse de ce que
subit ce nombre de collectivités locales
dans le contexte énergétique actuel je
voudrais aussi rappeler que mon groupe
est réservé sur le nombre de critères à
retenir pour qualifier la grille
voltaïsme parmi les quatre critères
proposés un seul nous paraît insuffisant
il y a un risque certain de dérives vers
l'énergie culture alors que la
préservation des terres nourricières
doit primer sur tout autre considération
ayant conscience que derrière ce sujet
c'est notre modèle agricole qui est en
question tout en affirmant que les
agriculteurs comme tous les Français
peuvent être des contributeurs du mix
énergétique national c'est pourquoi nous
vous présenterons un amendement visant à
déployer des programmes de contrôle des
installations photovoltaïques sur
culture pour terminer nous souhaiterions
savoir comment les communes vont devoir
prendre en compte le zan dans les
projets d'énergie renouvelables à cet
égard il est nécessaire d'inscrire la
comptabilisation du zan dans un
dispositif de solidarité ou de
péréquation territoriale nationale
quelle est Madame la Ministre votre
position à ce sujet je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant madame
daphnécmadou pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre collègue de
Nice Saint-Pé c'est en prononcé sur les
articles relevant de la Commission de la
management du territoire et du
développement durable mon intervention
ne portera que sur ce délégué au fond à
la commission des affaires économiques
je ne peux commencer quand on félicitant
notre collègue rapporteur Patrick
Chauvet pour l'excellence de son travail
et pour l'attention particulière qu'il a
eu à essayer de trouver des solutions de
synthèse quel que soit la technicité des
sujets abordés
les apports de notre commission des
affaires économiques sont nombreux
insertion du stockage de l'électricité
dans le dispositif de la loi
facilitation de la production du biogaz
encouragement à la production
d'hydrogène vert ou possibilité de
renforcer les capacités des
installations hydroélectriques mais le
temps qui m'est imparti ne permettant
pas de tout traiter je me concentrerai
donc sur trois points le premier sans
doute le plus préoccupant pour les
territoires et bien sûr l'objectif de 0
artificialisation nette le fameux âne
qui inquiète avec la transition
énergétique les territoires se trouvent
confrontés à un conflit d'impératifs
écologique d'un côté il faut limiter
l'artificialisation pour préserver les
milieux naturels de l'autre il faut
construire et développer des
infrastructures énergétiques pour
décarboner notre mix
il est donc nécessaire d'articuler les
deux pour que l'artificialisation
énergétique ne phagocyte pas tout le
potentiel au détriment de l'aménagement
local et en l'état actuel du décret de
la nomenclature d'usage il fallait
impérativement en sortir les
infrastructures énergétiques
très exactement ce qu'a fait notre
commission sous la houlette de son
rapporteur
ce faisant elle a ouvert la boîte de
Pandore c'est le premier aménagement à
l'objectif zan depuis son adoption dans
la loi climat et résilience madame la
ministre il n'y en aura d'autres votre
gouvernement s'est déclaré favorable
nous les accompagnerons attentivement
avec pour ligne directrice de rendre
l'objectif zan applicable sur tous les
territoires sans le vider de sa
substance
le deuxième point que je souhaitais
aborder le partage de la valeur un
élément clé en matière d'acceptabilité
des projets de NR or le dispositif
initial en fléchant l'intéressement sur
les riverains donnaient l'impression de
vouloir acheter le silence on pouvait de
plus craindre que ce partage ne soit
dans les fêtes anecdotiques nous avons
adopté en commission une réorientation
qui augmente le montant du partage
puisque ce dernier était tendu à toutes
les EnR et que le versement forfaitaire
sera complété par une contribution
territoriale servante à financer des
projets locaux de transition écologique
de plus notre commission l'a rendu
collectif et public ce qui semble plus
sain et logique le dernier point que
j'aborderai en conclusion est plus
problématique il s'agit de la
déclinaison territoriale des objectifs
de production d'énergie décarbonée
comment satisfaire nos besoins nationaux
avec des projets non pas seulement
acceptés mais même voulu par les
territoires
concernant les éoliennes terrestres la
problématique et caricaturale et
clivante mais elle se présente en
réalité pour toutes les énergies bas
carbone des centrales jusqu'au Pato
photovoltaïques en passant par la
production de gaz
nous devons trouver un système de
gouvernance de la transition énergétique
qui conserve toujours cet équilibre
entre objectif de production et soutien
territorial or ce dispositif nous ne
sommes loin de la voir notre commission
a néanmoins commencée à poser les jalons
en permettant aux collectivités qui le
souhaitent d'améliorer leur
planification énergétique via le schéma
de cohérence territoriale le Scott et de
manière simplifiée demain la
programmation plurianielle de l'énergie
devrait nous apporter un cadre global
c'est du moins un tel cadre que nous
appelons de nos vœux et madame la
ministre nous serons à vos côtés pour
l'élaborer
merci chers collègues la parole au
dernier orateur inscrit monsieur
Stéphane piennois pour le groupe les
République pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues au moment d'examiner
ce projet de loi nous sommes nombreux à
nous interroger tant sur sa finalité que
sur les moyens envisagés
accélérer mais pourquoi faire dans quel
but et avec quelle visibilité
votre objectif primordial est-il de
limiter drastiquement nos émissions
carbone dans ce cas il faut bien pointer
l'incohérence d'une démarche qui
consiste à isoler une thématique
particulière seule celle des seules
énergies renouvelables au lieu de
prendre le sujet de notre mix
énergétique dans sa globalité
certes dans une espèce de parallélisme
des formes le gouvernement nous
proposera bientôt un texte analogue
concernant la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires mais ce texte
aurait très bien pu être intégré au
débat du jour avec le mérite de
considérer plus globalement les forces
et faiblesses de notre production
électrique
une mesurons d'ailleurs toujours pas la
réalité concrète de notre politique dans
le domaine du nucléaire quelle est la
stratégie du président Macron en la
matière celle des années 2017-2019
conduisant à la fermeture des réacteurs
de Fessenheim et à l'arrêt du programme
de recherche Astrid ou bien celle des
années 2020 2022 avec les annonces
successives de relance du nucléaire sans
toutefois aller jusqu'à la signature de
commande à ce jour quand le en même
temps se traduit par le Stop and Go les
effets sont catastrophiques
d'autre part notre programmation
plurauelle de l'énergie est intenable et
multiplier les objectifs plus ambitieux
les uns que les autres et si possible à
un horizon très lointain il change rien
comme cela a été souligné par notre
rapporteur Didier mandeli redéfinir
notre PPE était un préalable à toute
discussion sur les orientations à
prendre pour les prochaines décennies
encore une occasion ratée de mener un
débat de fond et si possible des
passionnés
accélérer nécessite évidemment d'avoir
une certaine visibilité du point de vue
méthodologique l'idéal serait même
d'avoir une feuille de route un
itinéraire clair avant de s'engager sur
une voie d'accélération à minima
connaître la direction d'un déplacement
et d'une utilité certaine pour quiconque
envisage de prendre la route
dans la ministre l'initiative du
gouvernement ne coche aucune case ni
visibilité ni feuille de route ni
direction bien identifiées et pour tout
dire même la boussole fait des faux
mes chers collègues sommes-nous bien
certain de vouloir accélérer dans le
brouillard d'une politique publique si
essentielle tant pour notre
développement économique que pour notre
souveraineté d'un point de vue très
personnel tout cela me fait penser à la
copie d'un mauvais élève de
mathématiques que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et serait au
passage de nous dissimuler dans laquelle
on trouverait pêle-mêle et sans aucune
logique un tas de théorème inapproprié
censé mener à une conclusion dont on ne
discernerait plus du tout les contours
aussi dans la grande sagesse du Sénat
que votre gouvernement reconnaît
désormais régulièrement et souligne même
tout particulièrement depuis quatre mois
les commissions saisies ont tenté de
remodeler ce texte pour mieux encadrer
certaines dispositions je citerai en
particulier les simplifications
envisagées en matière du droit
d'urbanisme que les rapporteurs ont
voulu davantage laisser entre les mains
des élus locaux
et le régime de partage de la valeur
prévue dans l'article 18 en préférant
une redistribution publique et
collective à une redistribution privée
et individuelle suspecte de vouloir
éteindre le feu des contestations avec
quelques pièces 7 empruntées au budget
de la Nation
je salue donc le travail des rapporteurs
qui ont réussi malgré cette confusion
des intentions et cette absence de
rigueur dans l'approche méthodologique
du gouvernement à produire un texte plus
pragmatique et plus proche des réalités
du terrain je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale éclose la parole est évidemment
à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs peut-être
quelques mots d'abord pour saluer les
apports des différents groupes dans le
l'analyse de ce texte ce sont des
avancées qui je pense vont contribuer à
l'objectif de production de plus
d'électricité bas carbone dans les
années qui viennent
mais j'entends aussi
de nombreux groupes qui évoquent le
sujet du veto préalable des mers je dis
préalable parce que vous l'avez compris
c'est un veto qui interviendrait très en
amont des projets et sans qu'on ait pu
analyser l'impact économique énergétique
environnementale
paysagers des projets en question il
faut le nommer tel qu'il est et donc
reconnaître ce qu'il fait c'est à dire
bloquer potentiellement des projets je
ne crois pas que ce soit
l'ambition que j'ai entendu de la part
de chacun des groupes qui ont pris la
parole donc je renouvelle ma proposition
en rapporteur trouver le dispositif
équilibré qui concilie accélération et
participation des élus qui doivent avoir
le dernier mot
j'ai aussi entendu vos remontées sur le
sujet du traitement des dossiers et des
ressources humaines donc je veux le
redire ici
oui l'État doit se mettre en position de
mieux s'organiser pour permettre le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
et c'est ce que nous avons fait comme
vous le savez nous avons d'abord
renforcé le budget vous avez la
direction générale énergie climat et les
dréals qui ont été renforcés de 37 ETP
37 ETP c'est historique dans le budget
du ministère de la transition
énergétique et écologique je rassemble
les deux ça fait 20 ans qu'on n'a pas vu
de tels renforcement d'équipes
nous avons également
chirurgiendrai monsieur le sénateur nous
avons également
envoyer une circulaire au préfet qui les
mettent en position non seulement
d'animer leur propre équipe d'aller
chercher des solutions d'accompagner les
élus de mettre à disposition des
cartographies des élus locaux pour aller
plus vite et déterminer avec eux les
zones qui sont le plus propices aux
énergies renouvelables tout ça est
également embarqué nous avons bien tenu
compte des retours notamment du Conseil
national de la transition énergétique
auquel participent un certain nombre
d'associations d'élus et d'associations
environnementales et d'organisation
syndicale et de représentants des
entreprises
cette loi elle nous avons également
pardon je veux le rappeler
signer un décret sur le contentieux qui
permet d'accélérer les contentieux il
est tout frais il date du 29 octobre et
il réduit à 10 mois les périodes de
contentieux au tribunal administratif à
la cour administrative d'appel
entraînant l'absence de décision du juge
un passage automatique à l'instant
supérieur voilà des décisions très
pragmatiques qui montrent que nous
abordons la question la production des
énergies renouvelables de la manière la
plus analytique possible qu'est-ce qui
bloque les projets comment on peut lever
ces blogages comment on font on peut
permettre offenser de disposer d'une
énergie bas carbone en abondance et
compétitive en prix et je vais donc
passer à la question qui est venue sur
la question de la stratégie je crois que
la stratégie vous la connaissez vous
avez même
passé trois heures j'étais
malheureusement retenu par mon covid
mais la première ministre a été devant
vous pour répondre à toutes vos
questions sur la stratégie énergétique
du gouvernement c'était il y a deux
semaines la stratégie énergétique du
gouvernement vous la connaissez parce
qu'en fait elle s'éteignent sur les
différents scénarios de RTE et je crois
que RTE était auditionné encore hier
sauf erreur de ma part
qui sont construits sur la base d'un
travail de deux ans qui n'existe pas
dans d'autres pays européens en tout cas
et je ne crois pas qu'il soit si
approfondie dans des pays de l'OCDE et
qui pas à pas construit une perspective
de production énergétique sur la base du
nucléaire et des énergies renouvelables
en donnant des potentiels en traçant des
scénarios et en traçant aussi des
scénarios de réduction de la
consommation puisque le sujet de la
sobriété l'efficacité énergétique vous
l'avez compris sera aussi au cœur de nos
enjeux énergétiques et je veux rappeler
par rapport à cette boussole qui existe
qui est connu que nous avons aussi
respecté la décision du Parlement qui
veut que nous lançons un débat public
très large ce que nous nous avons fait
ce débat public a démarré en octobre il
fait l'objet aujourd'hui de 8000
contributions en moins de deux semaines
ce qui n'est pas rien ce qui témoigne de
l'intérêt des Français pour ce débat et
donc non nous n'allons pas forcément les
choses simplement nous avons un acquis
c'est la précédente programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie comme beaucoup
d'entre vous l'ont signalé nous sommes
en retard sur les énergies renouvelables
donc faut-il
attendre encore sur les énergies
renouvelables alors que nous savons tous
que s'il y a un sujet sur lequel nous
pouvons être d'accord et vous l'avez
communément dit c'est qu'il faut
accélérer sur ce sujet là et bien sûr
nous construirons ensemble la
trajectoire de programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie il me semble important
aussi de revenir sur un point sur
l'énergie nucléaire à aucun moment
depuis le lancement du programme
électronucléaire le nucléaire a dépassé
20% de notre consommation d'énergie 20%
je pense que c'est important de le dire
parce qu'il y a souvent une confusion
lorsqu'on a pas on aborde les détails
énergétiques entre électricité et
énergie or l'énergie c'est aussi la
chaleur et c'est le carburant pour se
déplacer et ce qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui dans la transition
énergétique c'est précisément
de se passer du carburant de se passer
du gaz pour se chauffer et c'est là que
nous allons avoir besoin à la fois de
réduction nos consommations et que nous
allons avoir besoin de nucléaire et ce
chiffre va peut-être vous surprendre
mais depuis 2000 nous avons renforcé
notre résilience énergétique nous sommes
moins dépendants de l'extérieur que nous
n'étions en 2000 en 2000 nous étions
dépendants pour notre consommation
d'énergie à 72%
d'importation 72%
en 2020 ce qui est encore plus proche
nous sommes dépendants
d'importations je dis pas que c'est
formidable 65% je signale juste que par
rapport à la représentation qu'on peut
s'en faire on a réduit cette dépendance
à des énergies importées et je pense
qu'il est très important d'avoir ce
débat et de ne pas confondre
l'électricité énergie parce que c'est
probablement un des sujets qui créent de
la confusion et notamment chez les
Français et donc j'appelle moi aussi ce
débat de fond des passionnés sur
l'énergie c'est celui que nous verrons
en 2023 sur la prochaine programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie mais vous savez
déjà les grands axes de ce que nous
proposerons puisque le président de la
République il y a maintenant huit mois à
annoncé très clairement son souhait de
relancer la construction de 6 EPR
nouveau il a également annoncé son
souhait de mettre à l'étude 8pr
additionnels il a également signifié que
nous allons nous engager dans une
stratégie de réduction de la
consommation en se calant sur les
scénarios de RTE il a enfin précisé
quelle était la trajectoire qu'il
recommandait en matière d'énergie
renouvelable avec une multiplication par
10 d'ici 2050 de notre production
photovoltaïques et l'installation de 40
gigawatts d'éolienne marine tout ce
débat nous allons la voir il a enfin
indiqué que nous prolongerons les
centrales nucléaires le haut maximum en
tenant compte évidemment de la sécurité
nucléaire et dernier point sur ce sur ce
sujet des centrales
lorsque nos prédécesseurs ont lancé le
programme électrolinaire ils l'ont lancé
pour 40 ans
personne n'ignorait lorsque c'est
centrales nucléaires ont été mises en
service entre 1977 et le début des
années 80 que 40 ans plus tard
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui
nous allions passer des visites de
contrôle qui allaient passer durée plus
de 6 mois personne ne l'ignorer personne
ignore d'ailleurs que dans 10 ans le
même exercice sera fait et qu'il sera
plus difficile puisque les centrales
nucléaires auront 10 ans de plus et
comme toute équipement il est soumis une
forme d'obsolescence liée à son
utilisation il y a une partie il y a une
partie des composants qui sont
remplaçables et ça on peut le faire
autant qu'on veut il y a une partie des
composants d'une centrale nucléaire qui
peuvent tenir à qui peuvent à un moment
de voir ne seront pas remplaçables c'est
par exemple l'exemple de la cuve donc
tout cela est connu sans surprise et
aujourd'hui nous devons effectivement
parce que nous sommes dans une crise
énergétique qui nous montre que les
importations sur lequel nous avons
compté depuis mais depuis la sortie de
la deuxième guerre mondiale pour prendre
cet échéance là je vais pas remonter
à des temps en temps et diluviens c'est
importations elles ne sont pas acquises
elles ne sont pas acquises parce qu'il y
a des arrières pensées géopolitiques
nous le voyons avec la Russie elles ne
sont pas acquises parce que la
transition énergétique dans lequel nous
sommes engagés augmentent les prix de
ces importations elles ne sont pas
acquises non plus à un prix compétitif
parce que nous payons et c'est bien
légitime le prix de l'atome carbone du
pétrole et du gaz et que c'est tout
l'enjeu que nous avons de faire face à
un sujet de déréglement climatique donc
je crois que aujourd'hui plus personne
ne peut minorer l'impact je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre je passe donc
au texte de la Commission à l'article 1a
je suis saisi d'un certain nombre
un certain nombre de pris